hey imax fans i'm aaron eckhart check
out this clip with the director stuart
beattie talking about our new film i
frankenstein in imax 3d don't miss it
imax is really all about bringing you
into the film and having you experience
the film rather than just watching the
phone you really feel like you're in
those locations when it's all around you
and you cannot see anything else and i
frankenstein is that kind of movie it's
actually a third more film you get to
see watching it through imax when you're
shooting a film is a little rectangle on
your view fighter showing you what
regular cinemas are going to see but
then there's also the top on bottoms of
the frame that only imax viewers are
going to see
we've added in the bottom and the top of
the frame from the original for k- we
haven't just blown up the little bits in
the middle it really is a whole
different move you can see it once in
the regular theaters and see it in imax
and you'll say that was a completely
different movie I really wanted to give
viewers the most value possibly gear
that's a real rush you want to know what
it's like to be in a room with a
Frankenstein creature go see i
Frankenstein and I'm at